[Applause]
third and 10 come the gun Barclays hit
as he throws it up in the New England
defense comes up big that was the game
ceiling interception is called biiian
Eagle now let's play iron Eagles great
read of a promo for young Sheldon
followed by an all-new episode of the
new hit comedy number one called the
unicorn oh we don't have that we don't
have that okay I'm sorry
here's Iron Eagle back on the rich shots
and show hari iron coming up on CBS Bob
Lowe's Abba Shola I hate to call you out
it's it's Bob Hart's Abba Shola yes
coming up on CBS Bob Hart's
Abbott show I can't believe look on the
card rich guy I don't know what's really
going on how are you all right by the
way Diane is that your doorbell like
when they ring your doorbell like that's
that's that's the sound that's the seed
that's the music they like there's
somebody there's another path tremendous
idea that it's not but it's gonna be my
doorbell from now on that's outstanding
oh man how are you I am ego how you
doing you go I'm good let's go good yeah
been running around a little bit nice to
be an orchard park and blend in with the
pregame festivities
yeah get a real feel for what it's what
it's like out there it has religious
experience speaking of which there was a
wedding at half-time between two Bills
fans that met at the game years ago iein
did you yeah did you watch that or are
you just getting ready no I did I
watched it it felt like one of those old
Mooney weddings that you and I
experienced when we was growing up yeah
it was no it was beautiful it was a
really really nice thing that the bills
did Kyle Williams officiating that's
right Ellie
walk the bride down the aisle and former
bills and attendance and you know here's
the thing about Buffalo which to me is a
great thing it's
not the norm anymore in the NFL normally
at halftime around the league people
just go elsewhere they they spill into a
luxury suite or a VIP area they're going
to have drinks they're going to have
food they're going into the concourse in
Buffalo they stay they stay in the seat
so this was a legitimate 70,000 people
watching this wedding it was incredible
well I mean and and the fans there
almost got their wish for in the bride
and groom I'm sure they would rather be
registered for a win than anything else
I mean they almost got it iron I mean
what did that you know how we are in the
media about a blueprint did a team show
a blueprint do the bills actually show
one on what what could be done for for
the rest of the AFC with New England do
you think here what I think what they've
shown is a lot of progress there's no
doubt that what's happened in Buffalo
has been an alignment of ownership front
office and head coach / coaching staff
they're all three on the same page and
there has been a culture change you can
feel it when you talk to the players
when you walk around that facility it's
a different vibe than it had been in
previous years so give a lot of credit
to show on McDermott and to the Pegula's
this to me is the start of something now
they didn't get the result they were
looking for but defensively they're
going to be able to compete with a lot
of teams in the NFL they gave Tom Brady
fits that was real that wasn't just
Brady having an off day that was Buffalo
dictating the tenor on defense they've
got a legitimate pass rush their
secondary is very tough and they've got
playmaking linebackers so to me the
improvements are going to have to come
on the other side of the ball and it's
going to fall on the development of Josh
Allen and whether you're an Allen
believer or not that was his 15th NFL
start how he was injured was a brutal
head but it was also Allen putting
himself in harm's way I think he does
try to do a little too much at times and
his instinct and at some point he's
gonna have to flip the switch on that
and and realize that it's okay don't
force it down the field three times off
your back foot on a long ball and get
picked off by the New England defense
don't go for that one extra yard and
leave yourself open for for a hit that
knocks me out of the game these are
learning experiences for him
well obviously bills France would say he
didn't knock himself out of the game it
was a hit that would normally get
somebody ejected if it was on Tom Brady
I mean even Bill's players were we're
mentioning that about that hit what was
what was the first blush reaction I
guess you're in a commercial break view
it with you and Fouts as you threw a
break with Josh Allen on the ground
there yeah I was a rough hit from
Jonathan Jones there's no doubt about it
the play basically had been made and
then Jones slid in as the secondary
tackler look I think Josh Allen
certainly didn't put himself in the best
of positions he was also leaning forward
with his helmet and we understand that
the onus is on the defensive player but
I think there is responsibility for the
offensive players as well when Allen
tucks it and runs which happens quite a
bit teams are going to be looking to
make him pay not make him pay by getting
a huge penalty or getting not thrown out
of the game as the defensive player but
in part of the game is to change the
game as a defender and they changed the
game Matt Barkley had to come into the
game and could not lead them back
if Josh Allen is still in the game
there's a chance Buffalo does come back
and maybe create some late-game magic so
yes 100%
the hit was illegal I don't think he's
going to be suspended from the hit but
you can understand that there is a
feeling that there are different rules
for different people but Tom Brady just
wouldn't put himself in that spot I've
done so many Brady games through the
years he's so wise and savvy when it
comes to those plays he also understands
longevity clear I mean yeah no doubt
about that I mean just on that point
before we move on a little bit here I an
eagle on the Rich Eisen show what is it
like
being in a pre broadcast meeting with
Dan Fouts and Tom Brady put me as a fly
on that wall
well here's the thing Dan was an anchor
in San Francisco a sports anchor right
during a stretch of his career while it
was doing college football he was also
anchoring the local sports of KPIX when
Tom Brady was a senior in Northern
California so Dan did a walk and talk
interview and we have the video we're
talking that we've used it before of Tom
Brady at 18 years old and they formed a
bond obviously back then if you're Brady
and Stan Fouts you know clearly at that
stage of your life you're just blown
away that a Hall of Fame quarterback the
great Dan Fouts is chatting with you and
is interested in what you have to say so
now the years go by we met with Brady so
many times and being in that production
meeting it's two guys that get along
really well and tom is very comfortable
I think Tom it's probably the best guy
in the NFL rich when it comes to
production meetings yet City understands
he does he just not understands what
it's all about he he understands what we
need and he I think also understands how
the dynamic works the other way
good questions will bring good answers
and Tom is that type he's he's really
insightful in those sit down so he and
Dan I definitely have a long-term bond
that will carry on for many years all
right now do Belichick meetings are part
of the job that's of course does
understand that and here's the thing
with Bill in all seriousness yes if you
if you get into certain subject matters
oh yeah he can be delightful completely
delightful he'll talk about NFL history
and give you things that that you hadn't
even thought about angles and and
different things that have happened at
his perspective on them to get into
officiating he is very strong because he
knows that rule
backwards and forwards if you get into
the opponent he can be very good it's
really when you get into his team it's
right that you're not gonna get a whole
lot in a shed or who said it yeah or
himself right if you start other than
how he related to people throughout his
career if you ask him about lawrence
taylor carl banks if you ask me about
Bavaro i said he coached under Ted
marchibroda yes got made so many stories
it's amazing he's old he's an
encyclopedia of football as you
experience and I did ask him by the way
about the NFL 100 the a stuff that he
did with you when we met with in week
two okay and his eyes lit up he smiled
ear to ear that's how much he enjoy I'm
not just telling you this because I'm on
your show I would tell you this if we
ran into each other at an airport yes
sir he was he was tickled to talk about
that and he said it was a great
experience
and I know everybody's looking forward
to it there's no question I've said it
on the show and I'll say it here and
I'll say it to you in an airport when I
probably that's probably where it was a
top-five career highlight for me doing
that show with Collinsworth and him he
is dynamite if he does want to do
broadcasting he does have the chops for
that he really really does you know no
doubt he is he is scary smart and bright
and brings a unique perspective look
I've done these meetings for 22 years
you get some coaches that want to chat
and it's just a little BS session back
and forth you get other coaches that
play close to the vest it's your job to
figure out what of that information as
you disseminate it is usable and worthy
of a broadcast to just say you spoke to
someone isn't enough there's got to be
something of value that can either move
a story ahead or at least bring a
different angle to it and you pick and
choose your spots bill understands the
whole set
he chooses not to use it as a way to
grandstand or to get points across he
just goes out coaches his team and look
if you ask good questions there are
times where he can give you something
that could be worthwhile I an eagle here
on the Rich Eisen showing reason why in
Airport is a place that you're likely to
be seen certainly during the football
season is this wasn't your first game of
the week involving a future first ballot
hall-of-famer where's number 12 you did
the Westwood one radio call of the
Eagles shocking Aaron Rodgers where what
what what do you think we learned about
the Eagles from that game I an eagle
moving forward here yeah no relation
maybe maybe like fourth cousin on my
father's side maybe I'd have to check
family tree what I what I think we
learned is that there probably was an
overreaction after the first few weeks
the Eagles were a few places away from
being through you know and I know there
are a lot of teams I could say that but
they truly were Carson Wentz and company
maybe there's now an understanding of
look they've got to run the football and
be effective in that part of their
offense and the fact that they establish
Jordan Howard that mile Sanders has
really shown a knack they're better in
that part of their game then was exhibit
in the first three weeks once they get
the Shawn Jackson back that changes the
dynamic through the air al Shawn Jeffery
gave them a huge left and then
defensively they did just enough and we
could question the play calling at the
end of the game for Green Bay and you
would be legit in questioning it because
if you don't have trusted you can punch
it in from the one you might have some
deeper issues that's a different story
for the Packers the injury to Jamal
Williams didn't help but I I think
Philadelphia is in better shape than if
you and I had this conversation one week
ago the perception around the league was
that they were in big trouble they're
not and so when it all comes down to it
ion you're gonna see Ravens and steel
next week you'll be watching obviously
the Monday night game they'll prepare
for that best team you've seen through
the first four weeks would be well we'd
still be Kansas City to me their offense
is still beyond what anybody else has
defensively it's coming along that's
going to take some time I think that's
why you would say that instinctually New
England will be there when what it
counts of course but there's a reason
why New England was getting an e Antonio
Brown business I think they realize that
they're down a major playmaker there's
there's something missing from this
offense that would make them the team to
beat no questions asked
that's not to say that they're not going
to be there when the smoke clears I'm
sure they will because it's who they are
and they figure it out they
problem-solve
throughout the year but yesterday was an
example of that they just didn't have
that that dynamic downfield target and
the chemistry that probably would have
formed between Brady and Brown is what
made it so enticing now there are so
many other things that came into play
and there are things were not privy to
that came into play and there's a reason
why he's not there anymore but from a
football standpoint I believe that they
felt that he would have been a missing
piece for them with that said Kansas
City would be the best team I've seen so
far in person I an eagle before I let
you go congratulations folks here in Los
Angeles that are very excited for their
Clipper season and it's you could make
the argument the most exciting Clipper
season ever is going to hear on the
radio the voice of Noah Eagle hired at
age 22 to be the radio voice of the Los
Angeles Clippers now that is a direct
relation correct I mean well we're still
checking it's your son iron breaking
news it's your son congratulations well
there was rumors of a Poland Spring
delivery man
six well when I was away coming to you
straight from Maine it is you're welcome
he is he is beyond excited to be living
with you for six months which I don't
even know if you were aware of but my
wife and I have done this before we are
we're we're good people seriously if
your son needs a place to hang a meal or
whatever I'm sure I'll be doing fine
I'll be on the road looks like you quite
a bit but you know yeah but it's awesome
and what the Clippers have done during
the offseason to me they are the deepest
team in the NBA they've got the horses
to to make serious noise and maybe even
bring a championship to LA I know the
way things are set up in Los Angeles are
very similar to how they're set up here
in the New York area between the Knicks
of the net so battling for credibility
and relevance is always something that
comes into play the Clippers have done
that the Nets have done that as well so
it's it's this bicoastal Eagle thing
that we got going yeah it's really good
to be fun four teams of the eager to
change the script on the teams that
supposedly rule the basketball roost in
town and and those Nets Clippers games
I'm sure will be a terrific moment for
you and so I'm thrilled congratulations
on that brother yeah thank you rich you
got appreciate and then I'm also pleased
to say this is my new ringtone for for
when you call there you go
it is iconic isn't that amazing when
this music came out and you'd never
heard it now do you think I don't know
really
and now all these years later like no
that's football that feels like Sunday
football it also feels like Bob Hart's
Abba Shola to me I'm tryin but that's
just me that's also you know work on
that by the way that the neighborhood's
on before Bob Hart's Abba Shola that's
those are all new coming up on CBS I
believe tonight as a matter of fact I
and thankfully they call man all right
rich thank you thanks to Cedric the
Entertainer
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app